um dr. Aaron I live in Ashland Oregon
I've been a chiropractor for 17 years
I'm also a life coach and I am really
all about helping people just live their
most extraordinary lives feeling amazing
in their body and really having a fun
and energized relationship with money
also is they're not different
there they go hand-in-hand physical
health and financial health totally work
together which is why I'm so fired up
and excited about what we've got going
on here are you first and foremost with
Kevin's been talking about the oil what
we've got is honestly the world's best
hemp CBD oil on the market you guys have
to understand how exciting this is
because you know you may or may not know
CBD cannabis is the next booming
industry going from 7 billion over 50
billion years to come the next few years
so it's just what's up right now it's go
to achieve those conversations people
want to know where to get it how to get
it how to get involved right invest how
to become a what is being called this
green mush so it's really really
exciting that we've got the best of the
next blooming industry paired with the
ground floor of this epic aster yet
marketing company that's run by these
seller
people that you know Kevin's been
sharing with you so the oil why is it
the best I mean how can I honestly sit
here and tell you that what we've got is
the best first you know grown
internationally organically on mammoths
and farmed organically for many many
years on co2 extraction for those
sovereign observables of pesticides
fungicides bra as oils to Colorado where
it starts with nanotechnology like
having the same basically breaking the
particles around into small diapers own
bubbles so that the CBD can get into the
part of the cell where it needs to go to
work it's magic
we need this oil right now we actually
have an exogenous cannabinoid system era
bodies we have receptors for CBD in the
brain and the nervous of some but
because we're so deficient in nutrients
and so overloaded for content this
endogenous cannabinoids system isn't
working the
way of firstly working this was
discovered about 30 years ago not even
it's going to be prevented be one of the
single most important medical
discoveries of all times
basically this endogenous cannabinoids
system is responsible for homeostasis
which simply means the body functioning
and maintaining and doing what it's
supposed to do so basically the script
declare their amount absorbs under our
time in 30 to 60 seconds because of
every single ingredient that is praised
by our world renowned chemist in the
bottle it's five to ten times more
absorbable it goes right into that part
of the cell where it needs to go to
support this endogenous cannabinoids
system and what happens when this system
is nourished and nurtured and fed and it
supports healthy anti-inflammation
antioxidant anti stress an immuno
regulator helps the nervous system
protein fighter flight or survival mode
where we can't heal where we can't
create our most awesome life where we're
only focused on surviving makes the
nervous system from survival into
parasympathetic where we can then you
know really wake up ourselves wake up
our body consumption the wasteful
function our minds and functional a
social function so it's really really
important that whether you want it you
know really take a look at this from a
customer viewpoint or from you know
deciding to join our company and partner
with us and really become a bit you know
forefront as a pioneering health
revolution either or it doesn't matter
but really I want you to pay attention
to what we've got going on there because
it's so so super important for people
can be taking a CBD to be replenishing
that endogenous cannabinoids system we
have been put in practice for 17 years
and I'm blown away by the results that
people are getting a memorial physically
yes absolutely but also emotionally
mentally I believe spiritually you know
I do is I'm a spiritual person I believe
dr. coil brought back to us to really
wake us up like heaven said not about
the
GHC this isn't about getting you high
point zero two percent THC this is the
pure CBD going into the cell waking up
the cell so that we can be the best
version of ourselves which ultimately is
what this company is about you know when
we pair this amazing next level that's
hemp oil on the planet so again the best
of the next booming industry paired with
the ground floor of this you know
affiliate marketing company that hasn't
even launched yet I mean you're just
it's a very very very beginning of you
know like I said pioneering this comes
revolution globally you know hundred
percent legal in all 50 states and we
going global
this is an extraordinary opportunity and
the six months I've been involved in
this company I have seen amazing results
of people physically and financially
because of our epic conference because
of the high level of support that our
company offers it's just you know you're
set up for success of course you can't
make any claims at this been healed
short street any disease or condition as
you can't make claims that you'll make
one penny here you know but you really
get out which you put in but because of
the pairing and the marriage of the next
looming industry with this ground floor
of company it's really something to take
a look at so I think that's what I
thought tonight and have an all Patrick
that's here
[Music]